وقم الاسعاف التابع لجمعيه ال الاحمر في
هذه الاثناء تصل مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
محمله بعدد من الشهداء من
زملائهم من المسعفين وساقي سيارات الاسعاف
الذين وصلوا مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير
البلح
قصفه من قبل الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
على مدخل مدينه دير البلح على شارع صلاح
الدين طواقم الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني تم قصفها قبل
قليل سيارات الاسعاف التابعه لجمعيه هلال
الاحمر وصلت مستشفى شهداء الاقصى للتو
تحمل عدد من زملائهم الذين كانوا في مهمه
لجلب الاصابات من مخيم المغازي ولكن
الطائرات الاسرائيليه قصفت سيارات الاسعاف
التابعه لجمعيه الال الاحمر وهذا الامر
ادى الى ارتقاء اعداد من الشهداء من طواقم
الاسعاف نناشد الجميع في العالم كله على
القيام بواجبهم نحو توقف الحرب الان قبل
يعني ان تتطور الامور ويصبح استهداف سيد
ارات الاسعاف التي تقوم بنقل المرضى كما
تم الاستهداف سابقا للمستشفيات والدوائر
الحكوميه
الاخرى اشرف ابو عمره لقناه الجزيره
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح